i love i love that now that um
i love now that everyone's bought into
tesla elon's like
maybe i should sell
oh everyone gives their money to him and
he's like well maybe i'll pay taxes now
well here's the thing here's the thing
he he said that he has a bunch of
options expiring this quarter anyways so
he has to sell otherwise they're going
to expire
so i don't know what that tweet was
about
making it seem like twitter is deciding
whether they're
yeah if you don't know what we're
talking about he tweeted this week and
he said much is made lately of
unrealized gains being a means of tax
avoidance so i propose selling 10 of my
tesla stock do you support this yes no
oh so you're just trying to get ahead of
it i don't know i have no idea it's also
like the [ __ ] this stock tanked on
monday because of this he's going to buy
back in
like
market manipulation is it not i think so
pretty crazy
yeah
yeah so he's gonna have to he's gonna
have a huge tax liability anyways at the
end of this year i'm pretty sure
yeah um so i don't know why he made it
seem or maybe he's
offering to do this on top of
all the money he's gonna have to pay in
taxes anyways yeah i don't know but i
thought the tweet of him replying to uh
who was it
um scott um no no not him it was it was
about the curing world hunger
that tweet oh i was thinking about the
one where he was like uh
why does your profile picture look like
you just came yeah what the [ __ ] is it
dude like you make enough money and
you just start turning to donald trump
man like yeah you just like you're like
oh i don't
play i mean
i already have to answer my own question
once you have enough money you don't
have to play by the rules oh yeah no
decent point the sackler family continue
sackler yeah who are they you know who
are the sacklers oh you're not gonna get
me are you
sackler
everyone everyone's baited breath right
now yeah yeah
that's gonna be the 2023
version of like movie deaths
instead of like the villain like gun of
the head
it's gonna be all scenes
hey bro
you heard of the sackler family what's
that who's this
have a sack of these nuts
no
no bring up the world hunger tweet when
he tweeted whatever he made like five
and a half billion dollars in one day or
something like that and he's like how
can this fix world hunger i'll give it
away
yeah taunting it in front of you yeah or
what was the what was the [ __ ]
organization that tweeted hey this could
solve world hunger you want to eat
i just i i thought it was pretty funny
that he turned around on them and was
like i'll do it i'll just give it to you
just prove how it's gonna be done two
percent of elon's elon musk's wealth
could solve world hunger says director
of un food scarcity and so then this
person calls him out saying that they
raised eight billion and they still
weren't able to do it so why do you need
elon's money yeah so he was like
i'll just as long as you can open source
your accounting and prove how this can
be done then i'll just give you five
billion dollars
oh my god dude yeah i mean i thought
that was a pretty funny response it's
hilarious yeah objectively funny them
like what ball's in your court now yeah
you gotta solve world hunger actually
he's a [ __ ] he is because he's kind
of above the law yeah he's like too big
to fail yeah it's like
and the government like relies on him
for like space travel
yeah they they need him to succeed so
when global warming happens they haven't
out yeah yeah exactly
we need to keep him going because how
else will all of us get to mars when all
of you die yeah that's
that's the thought yeah no they're
calling them weekly been like can you
just [ __ ] stop cut it out yeah that
was kind of funny but it stopped
yeah they're just they're all on
conference call elon
you know me and the guys were thinking
maybe i voted yes on that poll
me too me too
we think you should do it man come on
ten build us i had to vote no just to
keep it even
listen elon
it's funny it's all fun and games you're
[ __ ] around i get it just
pump the brakes a little bit just
we just
need you to make it easier on us so we
can keep things going yeah that guy's
pee pee do look like he coming
then elon
i want to pull my balls out on ig live
[Laughter]
oh
you do
huh well uh we would suggest i mean it
is funny you know
i was talking i was talking to joe and i
was
thinking to myself
no billionaire has ever pulled his balls
out on ig live
that is true that i don't know this
guy's [ __ ] insane it is true and uh
you know despite the fact that we do
think it would be funny right maybe
maybe the uh we wouldn't suggest
you could because the space
relies on you for and we don't
don't pull your when i pull my balls out
on ig no don't do that
hey hey elon hey hey
gary from uh
maine here yeah mayor uh
we talked about those kickbacks couple
years ago listen hey buddy
you know i got i got a
i got a son
and uh he kind of did something similar
you know he's not you he's not you but
he
it didn't it just
it didn't go well for him and i would
just imagine you know a guy of yours
you'll need to see my balls
you see that's what my son said as well
and it's just would be so funny
it's just looking like
i'm gonna teabag
my phone
live
they hit mute
i think we just got to let him do it i
think he just has to just we're just
going to let him do it
yeah you know what elon
shoot it man go for it
wonderful
oh yeah good chat good chat
i'm already live
you're live
this whole phone call
oh and my balls have been out the whole
time
[ __ ]
he [ __ ] pranked us
[Laughter]
billionaire elon pulls small balls out
on instagram live
this is an atrocity complete disrespect
for the modern
populous yeah my balls are quite nice
increase it yes
thousand dollars a share hello doge
daddy best balls online best balls in
finance best balls billionaire balls
moon balls moon balls
elon's balls are going to the moon we
need to create a dow for elon's balls so
we can vote where they come today i'll
be starting a dow for my balls
you can all volunteer which of your
wives i will come on to the first 500
token purchases will get a picture of my
dick to their tesla he's kind of the new
trump on twitter a little bit no he is
you know oh yeah all the news you know
trump or love trump he definitely left a
void on twitter
yeah you know if people are just trying
to power vacuum that uh that attention
yeah elon saw it all the news
organizations are you know
calling elon up yeah elon hi that's what
you think new york times yeah heard
you're gonna pull your balls out on
instagram live yeah
we'd love to cover it yeah we'd love to
cover the story yeah
exactly off the record eat those clicks
off the record we'd love to help
any way you'd like to get some more
coverage on pulling your balls out we'd
love to make a moment of this that's
just from me to you
you